[Musique]
je voulais vous parler du prochain
concert qui va avoir lieu à l'église
samedi à 20h30 samedi 2 avril c'est un
concert atypique original ce n'est pas
souvent que nous avons la chance d'avoir
des vrais musiciens d'europe de l'est
dont deux violonistes extraordinaire
c'est un groupe de musiciens d'europe de
l'est un des meilleurs groupes d'europe
de l'est vous savez que en ukraine c'est
un grand pays de musique et de voile
eric donc j'ai la chance de connaître
une association franco ukrainienne qui
s'appelle vesna il s'agit d'un groupe de
huit musiciens ukrainien qui viennent
spécialement
orgeval ce soir là
c'est symbolique et nous sommes très
attachés aux opérations caritatives ce
n'est pas la première fois nous avons
déjà accueilli
des syriens d argan des ukrainiens pour
nous c'était une évidence
l'entrée sera au prix de 10 euros et la
totalité des inscriptions sera reversée
à l'ukraine et aux associations
caritatives
intégralement
[Musique]